I think I've cracked something here, guys.
So whenever I do an interview,
I always get introduced as, like, our favorite boss babe,
our favorite boss lady,
our favorite boss chick, boss.
And I'm like,
I so get the sentiment behind.
I think it's really sweet,
but since when did we gender a job title
that was never gendered?
Like, I get the difference between waiter and waitress.
As outmoded as it is, those.
Those are both gendered, right?
But, like, when was there ever a boss or a bossette
or a boss and a bossess?
Like, I just don't understand.
My dad has never been called a boss dude or a boss bro.
Why am I getting called a boss babe?
Let's just bring it back, and let's just be like,
she's a boss.